thank you so much mercedes news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
to continue celebrating their 50th
anniversary southwest medical the
sponsors of this next segment are
helping down syndrome connections las
vegas here's more on their partnership
lofou you are with southwest medical
lisa you are with um
down syndrome connections las vegas and
this is a partnership we are excited to
spread the word about so let's start
with you low foo or dr tan
um you know you've worked you're a long
time provider with southwest medical
tell us more about the work that you do
with them
sure thank you yes i worked with
southwest medical for several years now
primarily in urging care in a couple
divisions uh one we call on demand
medicine and the other digital health
you know i was part of a team
that created a virtual telemedicine
program back in 2014
and the goal was to remove barriers like
lack of transportation
conflicts with work schedules
responsibilities around home and
personal life
that got in the way of getting
appointments
and uh
you know so for example
loading kids in cars and driving across
town or trying to find child care
or things that we're trying to remove
and since the introduction of that
program we've had
actually over a couple hundred thousand
audio visual
consultations on the platform for me
it's pretty rewarding to be able to
improve
healthcare and quality of life using
digital health technologies you know the
other thing is we're not the only
company
of course
in las vegas that is providing care and
as part of our 50th anniversary
we want to take the opportunity to
introduce some of our
community partners unless that takes us
perfectly to lisa tell us more about
down syndrome connection las vegas
we're a non-profit organization
connecting all people in the down
syndrome community with each other and
providing the advocacy and support that
they need and we are working closely
with the unlv school of medicine to
promote research to help people with
down syndrome be healthy live longer and
be fully included as members of society
as a whole
in october we're organizing the very
first las vegas down syndrome conference
at unlv and co-hosted by unlv
and in addition to registration for
parents and other interested members of
the community we'll be offering
registration for teens and adults with
down syndrome and have topics
specifically geared for them
as part of our 50th anniversary year
we're going to be introducing other
community partners
who
are involved in
providing care throughout southern
nevada and for us it's part of why it's
a great place to live and work
it sure is all right thank you again to
southwest medical for being one of our
community pride partners in las vegas
now we'll be right back